bonjour tout le monde je m'appelle
Hélène plrozec j'ai 25 ans je suis
conseillère départemental à Mayotte
membre du MoDem depuis un an et demi et
délégué fédérales des Jeunes Démocrates
au sein du conseil départemental j'ai
plusieurs fonctions donc je suis
présidente d'un groupe des lieux je suis
aussi en charge de toutes les questions
en lien avec l'éducation la formation
professionnelle l'insertion mais aussi
puisque nous sommes une collectivité
unique de la coopération régionale et du
développement économique j'ai commencé
mes études supérieures par une licence à
l'université de Ouran en Chine j'ai
ensuite poursuivi avec un master en
diplomatie générale à l'université de
Londres côté professionnel j'ai commencé
à travailler en tant que professeur
contractuel à l'Académie de Mayotte et
ensuite j'ai intégré le pulch formation
de la CCI Mayotte donc je suis née j'ai
grandi à Mayotte avec une double culture
puisque ma mère et mahoraise et mon
breton mais aussi beaucoup d'influence
au niveau politique ma mère est en de
gauche et mon père de droite pour moi le
centre était donc une évidence et c'est
surtout mon histoire son ancrage son
côté humaniste qui m'a attiré au modèle
donc Mayotte a un lien très fort avec le
modèle et en plus particulièrement avec
son président François Bayrou puisqu'il
a toujours été aux côtés des mahoraises
et des Maoré pour les événements
marquants de notre histoire tout d'abord
leur du référendum dans les années 70
pour rester français et ensuite lors de
la départementalisation en 2011 c'est
aussi une grande fierté pour moi d'être
une représentante politique locale parce
que notre histoire est marquée par
beaucoup de femmes pour le combat de
Mayotte française les femmes qu'on
appelait les chatouillesuses en ce
moment on a l'impression qu'il y a un
peu un désamour des outre-mer pour la
France métropolitaine en tout cas à
Mayotte c'est pas du tout le cas on est
fier d'être français et on rappelle
notre amour à la France autant de fois
que possible et pour votre consommation
notre devise c'est nous voulons rester
français pour être libre